So now let's go back to our split example. Let me
rearrange things a little bit to make more room. So now I'm
going to put the domains for size and for strength one next to
the other. So let's look at what some possible inputs will be
for the sub domains that we identified when we use the idea
of selecting input of the boundary. If we look at the first
subdomain, size less than zero, one reasonable input is, size equals to
minus 1, because minus 1 is the boundary value for the domain
of the integers less than zero. If we look at the third
subdomain, possibly interesting case is the one of size of equal to
1, for the same reasoning that we used for the previous subdomain,
for size less than zero. And, let's try to select another one
for this subdomain, for the integers greater than zero. If there is
a concept of maximal integer, we can select that one as our
boundary value. And of course we could select much more, but this
is just to give you an idea. Other possible inputs. One interesting
example for the first one, string with length less than
size will be a string with length size minus one. Again
this is the boundary value for this domain. And we could
continue in this way like for example selecting a string who's
length is exactly size as a boundary value for this
other domain. Instant one, and we look back actually to this
example and look at it in a more extensive way when
we actually talk about a specific method for doing this kind
of process.